відставка залужного і призначення
Генерала А сирського на посаду
головнокомандувача ЗСУ викликали чимало
запитань і суперечок серед українців за
офіційною версією озвученою Зеленським
керівництво ЗСУ потребує змін щоб
переглянути тактику дій і не допустити
стагнації лінії фронту у 2024
році торік Контрнаступ справді
провалився Україна дуже мало просунулося
там де це було необхідно головним чином
через те що росіяни підготували дуже
потуж оборону і зараз коли західні
постачання зменшилися дуже ймовірно що
війна так і буде залишатися в глухому
куті і Україна не зможе просунутися на
землі особливо з огляду на майбутні
вибори президента США тому я гадаю що
розглядаються інші підходи і зміна
керівництва ЗСУ сигнал про
це 23-й рік ми не досягли поставлени ми
не реалізували поставлені завдання і ми
знаходимось в ситуації що можливо 24-й
рік є
останнім роком коли у України є шанс
переламати ситуацію виходить що ті
генерали там не тільки генерал сирський
там є ціла когорта молодих генералів про
яких говорить Зеленський
вони мабуть заявили про те що вони
можуть на себе взяти відповідальність і
провести операції які зможуть переламати
ситуацію на фронті і створити умови за
будь-якого розвитку військово-статечної
обстановки за будь-якого розвитку
глобальної геополітичної обстановки
наприклад приходить до влади Трамп
західні експерти не виключають також що
причиною відставки залужного стали різні
погляди на подальше ведення бойових дій
у Зеленського і
екс-головнокомандувача залежить Кому Ви
вірите є офіційна версія яка полягає в
тому що потрібно змінити стратегію щоб
рухатися далі мовляв нам потрібна нова
кров це офіційна версія є й друга
причина можливо легітимніша яка полягає
в тому що новий головнокомандувач
генерал сирський справді більше
відповідає підходам Зеленського про
сирського кажуть і давно кажуть що він
дотримується більше радянських підходів
які більше направлені на досягнення
поставленої цілі тому я приміром не
сумніваюся що він вважає що українські
військові мають до останнього триматися
в авдіївці чого б це не коштувало так
само як він робив це під час бахмутської
операції яка на мій погляд і на думку
багатьох інших була ймовірно
помилковою
ці речі стосуються як політики так і
особистостей залужний організував захист
України у 2022 році Тож він назавжди
залишиться в підручниках історії але як
я вже згадував Контрнаступ у 2023 році
був трохи провальним і відтоді
Зеленський і залужний розходяться щодо
стратегії включно з цим дійсно важливим
питанням призову як залучити людей у
Збройні Сили України але є й інша річ
залужний дуже популярний і розглядається
як потенційний майбутній суперник
Зеленського на столі має з'явитися
реалістичний детальний план дій збройних
сил України на 2024 рік з урахуванням
реальної ситуації на полі бою зараз І
перспектив заявив Зеленський експерти
сподіваються що новопризначений
головнокомандувач ЗСУ сирський виправдає
такі очікування і зможе показати
результати з командующою сухопутними
військами це в складі збройних сил він
стає не просто
значить головнокомандующим збройних сил
цирський генерал А стає
главнокомандующим В умовах воєнного
стану сил оборони України Це інша
історія а крім того це складається в
важких
умовах стану дій на фронті тобто ворог
проводить стратегічну наступальну
операцію ми проводимо відповідно
оборонну операцію і про обмеженому
ресурсах і резервах це важкий стан тобто
в важкому стані на фронті Людина
заходить даже досвідчений генерал значит
і виконувать все це нові обов'язки дуже
важко це потребує від місяця і більше А
Фактор часу війні широкомасштабній яка
має місце зараз він виходить на рівень
стратегічний і дозволити цілий місяць -
це велики ризики як мені видається
що генерал сирський він сам як людина ну
така вольова цілісна він доволі такий
цікавий у своїх рішеннях генерал я за
ним спостерігав і він прихильник а
швидкої маневрової війни
А такого наступального типу навіть Ну
коли для цього є умови думаю що і
можливо було два підходи це перший це те
що Україна має перебувати виключно в
обороні а другий підхід він до кінця
2024 року а другий підхід він передбачав
що Україна має бути готова зокрема
застовести і а наступальні дії хоча б з
тактичними досягненнями локального
характеру але все ж і я думаю що якраз
призначення Олександра сирського як
людини такої досить
професійної досвідченої в веденні
наступальних дій м-м по-хорошому такої
авантюрної в хорошому сенсі це і є
відповідь Власне кажучи в принципі
обраної стратегії а далі ми вже побачимо
якісь плани які будуть оголошуватись і
тоді можна буде робити більше висновки
так Якщо ми візьмемо абстрактно оцінимо
двох генералів залужного і сирського то
Звісно що сирський формально найбільш
досвідчений генерал збройних сил України
він займав в тому числі
посаду і начальника Генерального штабу
тобто в тому що генерал сирський
представить
ее Верховному голокомандувачу детальний
план чіткий план на 24й рік Я в цьому не
сумніваюсь
це це однозначно якраз планувати
засовувати збройні сили генерал сирський
вміє Утім новому командуванню збройних
сил буде нелегко це зробити - зауважують
експерти особливо на тлі можливого
послаблення допомоги США тож потрібно
буде показати результати не лише
українському суспільство а й за кордоном
щоб там не поширювалася думка що Києву
час уже сідати за стіл переговорівщо Ну
можна план підготувати концепцію
стратегію але є реалії є реалії такі що
Сполучені Штати припинили фактично нам
допомагати Європа намагається е на чолі
з Німеччиною якимось чином компенсувати
але Звісно це не вдасться Бо Сполучені
Штати набагато більше допомагали ніж
Європа в цьому році ситуація
вирівнюється
очевидно було б краще допомогою
Сполучених Штатів ламати ситуацію на
фронті няти обстановку але ну маємо те
що маємо тобто в дуже складних умовах ми
знаходимося але шанс є і шанс цей
знаходиться в руках Генерала сирського
президент Зеленський нагородив Генерала
залужного званням героя України з
удостоянням ордену золота зірка експерти
не виключають що Валерій залужний
залишиться у військово-політичному житті
я би до речі не виключав Що Він
залишиться в команді президента на тій
чи іншій посаді Він же цього поки що не
заперечив не підтверджував тому варто
дочекатися його якихось заяв з цього
приводу Можливо він обійме якусь посаду
і буде далі
працювати в команді можливо ні Можливо
він дійсно захоче обрати політичну
кар'єру і буде цим займатися зрештою це
теж його право Ну поки що це питання
відкрите
[музика]